-Now, Kenan, you're always --
woop! --
incredible
on "Saturday Night Live."
Rrp.
-♪ I appreciate it ♪
-Now, since a big part
of that show is
thinking fast, on the spot,
I want to put your skills
to the test.
It's time for "Think Fast!"
♪ 1, 2, 3, Think Fast! ♪
-We're gonna take turns
drawing one of these cards.
Each card has five totally
random questions on it.
One person asks the questions,
the other person
has to answer each question
as soon as it's asked.
I mean, like, immediately.
Don't think.
Just go --
You basically --
-♪ 1, 2, 3, Think Fast! ♪
-♪ You got to think fast
on your toes, yeah ♪
-Yeah.
So, doesn't matter
if the answer is right or wrong,
just has to be
the first thing
that pops into your head.
Kenan, because you're the guest,
I will read the questions first.
-All right.
-You ready for this?
Can we have
a little lighting change?
-Ooh.
-What is a word
that doesn't rhyme with funk?
-Um, blam.
[ Laughter ]
-What's sweeter than candy?
-Sugar?
[ Laughter ]
-If cats could play jazz,
what would it sound like?
-♪ Meow meow meow meow meow ♪
[ Meow scatting ]
Is that a question?
[ Laughter ]
-Why you got to be so rude?
-'Cause, man.
[Bleep]
I almost said a curse word.
[ Laughter ]
It's real out here.
-That's my favorite one.
Why do you deserve heartburn?
-Hey, you know, you got make
better choices, you know?
[ Laughter ]
Better choices.
-All right, here we go.
Nice job on that, thinking fast.
Now, look...
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was some fast thinking.
Now it is my turn.
Kenan, whenever you're ready,
take the card
that's over by your section
and ask me the questions.
Can we dim the lights, please?
[ Clears throat ]
-[ Laughing ]
Why are ants so busy?
-Because they have to --
they feed their kids.
-Yeah, man.
Yeah, they do.
[ Laughter ]
What's the worst podcast called?
-"Showing Up
with Gill Gillerson."
[ Laughter ]
-All right.
What happened to the ducks?
-They started a business
and it's --
They're doing amazing overseas.
-That's good.
That's good.
-Amazing, amazing stuff.
-It's a global world.
-Yeah, it really is.
-It's one world.
Why was Teddy
so angry at you on Tuesday?
-Because of the party
that I didn't even know
that was being thrown for Teddy.
I was just there supporting.
And I'm like, "Dude, I had
nothing to do with it."
And he's like,
"Save it, mister."
[ Laughter ]
-Wow. And Teddy's from...?
-Teddy's from --
He's from, actually, England.
-Oh, got you.
-But he's an actor.
-Yeah, he tries -- yeah.
-He's an actor.
He was in character.
-That's cool.
He does good voices.
I like Teddy.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-What kind of man
microwaves his grapes?
-[ Voice breaking ] My --
My father.
-Oh, wow. This has gotten
really emotional.
-My fa-- My father.
-Let's just take a moment.
Let's, uh...
-I was swallowing my words.
My -- My father.
-Did he really do that?
-My dad.
My dad, his grapes --
-Did that disturb you
as a child?
-No, I'm fine talking about it.
-Okay.
-Anyway,
my dad microwaves grapes.
-That was chill, man.
That was a chill answer.
-It is time for the final round.
In this round,
we'll both pick up a card with
the same set of questions.
We'll ask and answer them one at
a time, going back and forth.
We'll go fast in this one.
Ready?
-Yeah. All right.
-All right?
Here we go.
I will go first.
One, two --
Where do bagels come from?
-The bread.
[ Laughter ]
-What's your new nickname?
-Uh, Scoopy G.
-Scoopy G.!
That's my dawg.
-[ Laughs ]
Why didn't we --
Why didn't we invite Erica?
-Because, man, you know,
she just has a hard time
getting home after, I guess.
[ Laughter ]
Why aren't you wearing shoes?
-Uh, because, uh,
I have, uh,
a problem called overarch,
where my feet are actually
round like Fred Flintstone feet.
-Oh, I gotcha.
So, you're, like,
walking on pebbles.
-Yeah, it's like
walking on a ball.
-Yeah, yeah.
Got it, got it.
-What does
a bear do in the woods?
-Come on. It does the thing
with the rabbit.
[ Laughter ]
What does your lower-back
tattoo say?
-Uh, uh, uh...
"Catch me outside."
[ Laughter ]
Where do baby pigeons come from?
Um...
♪ The ghetto ♪
I'm sorry.
[ Laughter ]
Give me some --
Give me some really bad advice.
-You know what you should do?
You should take all your money
and shred it.
[ Laughter ]
-That's cool, man, all right.
-Sing what you ate
for breakfast.
-♪ I think I skipped it ♪
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God!
♪ I think I skipped it ♪
-Sing the theme song
to "The Mandalorian."
Uh...
♪ Putting on a jet pack ♪
♪ And you're
flying around the space ♪
♪ Flying, look at the face
of what is life ♪
-♪ What is life ♪
-♪ It's a good show,
it's a great show ♪
♪ It's a one show,
it's a bingey show ♪
♪ But it's once a week,
and it's twice a week ♪
♪ It depends
which one you want ♪
♪ Mandalorian ♪
-Whoo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on!
That was "Think Fast"
with Kenan Thompson.
We both win.
-We win.
-We all win,
'cause we get to see you.
See him on "Saturday Night Live"
this Saturday!
And his new movie,
"Hubie Halloween,"
is on Netflix now!
Stick around.
-Adam Sandler.
-We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show."
Sandler, what's up?!
-♪ It's a good show,
it's a great show ♪
-♪ Flying and looking
for Baby Yoda ♪
♪ Working for... ♪